you stepped on one of them oh
hello
that's right they can hear you
welcome
back
to gamespot's all day marathon stream of
overwatch i'm here with eric tay how's
it going what's up
oh it's going really good now we don't
have
40 dollars of
loot boxes to open or do we but we have
something better
eric tay who's gonna
kill streak montage it for us oh that's
high hopes i have one loot box is that
better than nothing
yeah let's open it here take this oh
dwyer
man let's open up that loot box get a
legendary start off the stream with some
salt legendary i wanted oh got purple
that's not bad
hey girl all right that's actually
really rad equip
equip
we will equip that now we gotta get play
of the game i think that's oh what is
this
my man
let me preview
yeah yeah
all right victory pose oh this is just a
welcome how does this work
is that is that play of the game you
think i hope that's play the game
sorry i got all these no equip it equip
everything you know what i do need to do
is
dang that was good that made it worth it
all right
so do it that's all we get but you're
gonna earn more the old-fashioned way by
playing
so
let's find e a gamey
the old-fashioned way not the pay to
look good way
you know surprisingly enough though you
didn't
we were watching uh we were watching
that stream earlier when danny opened 51
loot crates and um
that you know that's a lot of money 40
bucks uh but you didn't it didn't seem
like you didn't think it was worth it
um
you mean me personally yeah i think i
think it's all relative it kind of
seemed like you thought it was worth it
no no i was trying to rationalize it and
say i'm gonna play may by the way gotta
get that may all day yeah um
yeah that works too those are things
that people say
i'm rhyming i don't know i don't know
yeah i don't know if i'd pay 40 bucks
that's kind of steep he only ended up
really if you think about it he got
pretty much four legendary skins worth
because he
got two uh at least he got two pretty
sweet ones he got zenyatta one and he
also got a uh reinhardt one both at
least were like good skins and
characters and then he got enough
potential and then he got enough hot
cash
to do it to buy two more so uh when we
were thinking about that you know
earlier that's you you're talking uh
10 bucks per ledge legendary essentially
which is about uh
if you compare to like heroes of the
storm yeah it's not
it's not bad but he got i think he got
some purples and stuff like that too so
i mean it's hard to say it's it's
definitely something there for
you know what they call the whales
to spend on you know
a million dollar whale
yeah you know how many boxes you get you
probably get doubles of everything by
that point just poured up some gold at
that point
uh well you guys uh while tay is playing
i am here to
uh talk about some of
the different tactics we're using
character lore and uh answer your
questions so if you have questions for
myself or ite about may
you please let us know freeze that guy
oh man
he just always dusts away
who's your least favorite character
that's something we don't talk about
enough we always talk about who we love
right like everyone loves uh
widowmaker and
reinhard it's like who do you who do you
think is an absolute [ __ ] character
i i don't think that there's an absolute
[ __ ] character i mean there's definitely
characters you probably don't play
as uh often or frequently because you
don't like them as much
uh don't worry i started that
i got you
oh what
today's day did i cancel my own ice
block or did you get me before that
we're about to find out
oh you got got me before it yeah does
that stun you the hook at all it does it
keeps you for a hot second yeah i think
it
when i'm typically hit but
i often play squishy characters
uh i always feel like the hook itself
kills me before i even get near him he
doesn't even have to do a follow-up
attack
uh anyway
reaper is kind of like my least favorite
character in terms of
mechanics i find him uninteresting
his alt is basically you walk in and you
hit a button and a lot of people die he
gets play the game a lot
uh but in terms of
you know learning the mechanics and kind
of playing them deeper
i i didn't find that he was a very deep
character but i don't think i've played
it enough to know if there's way more to
it than i think
yeah i mean
i i think
like you guys were saying earlier on the
lobby like you kind of learn new stuff
all the time right
and um
it's definitely gonna be
like i didn't like zenyatta at first and
then like i kind of
then you fell down
nice
i couldn't save you tracer sorry tracer
oh hello
freeze
you know
they coming for me i love that little
ice block
it's so good you just have to
oh he got hooked
yeah he did but he got the hook
on the point though
oh get sniped
uh junkrat has a really good counter to
may because he can basically put a trap
and a
like his oh they got a mine
on your ice and then when you come out
of your ice he'll just blow you up
because he can wait for you
oh you are frozen
nice to meet you
you can also use a lot of ice puns
i panicked damn it
we were on fire you were doing real good
i won that round though it's okay i'm
trying to play the game i watch that uh
hot intro we just got
oh right
yeah let's see it in action
i tried i don't think i got enough i
don't think i got it you think that's
play the game no i don't think so
i had a like a mini triple but it's
usually like i guess
i don't know i wasn't paying attention
to the rest of the people getting killed
so it's hard to say
goo was asking me about
bastion i like bastion i think he has
some
depth to him because
yeah well i mean he works really well
with other characters in the sense of
like uh he's got that
heavy medic combo thing going for him
where if you can get
uh
mercy to stay hidden and amplify your
damage he does work and he already does
work so it's really exciting to see them
work together um i mean you tell me
who's reaper work well with like who is
he like a good
combo he's pretty good with mercy i
guess mercy's good with anyone who's
like a big damage dealer i guess exactly
maybe i'm just hating on him oh i got
sniped by rain also i mean think about
it this way uh bastion when you use his
alt he
amplifies the powers he already has he
becomes a tank right so you have to
you have to walk around and you have to
shoot your cannon
better so it's making you better at your
skill you've already been using whereas
reaper
he's not making you better at your
skills
you're not doing anything
you you go into a room and you use it so
it's not about it's not about using it
good it's about getting yourself in the
proper position to use his alt
nice ice
that's not good though still oh but you
saved yourself again
are you playing with you don't have any
buddies with you do you oh yeah
they coming
oh i should have walled for the rest of
the team i'm gonna do it you still have
time
oh god
wall them out
oh yeah
it's sick when you can get one person in
because then they're completely helpless
without their friends yeah if you can
get them scrambling
kind of block their exit
yeah may is one of my favorites in terms
of
adding something to the game because she
does something nobody else does which is
she changes
the map i don't think there's any other
character that can actually have an
impact on
the layout of the map yeah she can
definitely split a team
she can really annoy team
um she's pretty good at capturing like
points as well she can like sit on one
my team is getting really bold they're
pushing up
pretty far
oh that guy just got pushed off oh
that's so sad someone behind you yeah i
think someone's like shooting me from
pretty far away the hanzo
not only does lucio like actively help
you and um
make you
give you a damage
like give you protection with a shield
but i also find that he's just
motivates me because he's got such a
lovely voice and he's always like making
me want to dance
i like his character a lot he's a pretty
good one
the audio medic
audio medic
man they're not even i'm not going to
play the game like this
you got to do work
to be fair though you guys are
capturing the point pretty good so
you'll probably at least
oh
okay
that is the surprise
why i don't know
i sabotaged my play of the game what
happened
i don't know it crashed oh
that's our first crash i was on fire
oh i'm joining back the game maybe i'm
still on fire maybe i didn't even die
oh overtime
i'm probably dead it's a shame
i'm dead and i lost my fire thanks a lot
game and i can't even see my gun i mean
it could have been worse they could have
like actually
all right maybe we can still get play
the game now oh it looks like they're
trying to defend it oh my god it's okay
we got we got some time i think
i'll group up with diva group up with me
okay how many do you think are in there
oh all of them
wallet
come on freeze them
yeah you all go oh no i got
you got snipped
i shouldn't have stood there that long
you're just free firing at that point he
was waiting for you to come out
i froze them all though come on it's
good
but it's a shame too because that's your
old dude if we lose this round because i
deceived i'm gonna be pretty salty cause
it kind of feels like that's what's
gonna happen
you got time i mean not a lot of time
but you still got time to fix this
it's really hard to contest this area
yeah we need group up
oh man you guys got a
this is it
you got a little ice here
go grab that roadhog
get back into the fight
all right
you guys are running out of time it's
eighty percent
that's fine this is it i think don't get
scared now
that would be the money i mean if any of
you guys haven't all now would be the
time
because it's set it's at 90. you guys
gotta go
now's the time
i can't somebody's got to go in there a
tank perhaps
all right i just put it down
such a good place to use it
oh this is oh you're in trouble
luckily you wasted his alt
make him squeeze them all right
i was by myself mary you did a great job
there was four of them you made reaper
waste is all because you were in your
little ice block but he still got you
wait come on somebody's in there
somebody not like this don't you think
it would have been cool if we didn't
crash may
could freeze the ground and she could
walk faster where she first grabbed the
cut scene that has that right
swear there was a point
where they thought about it and then
they just didn't do it and it breaks my
heart i can't believe we crashed we lost
because i crashed hmm
it didn't help yeah
because i had alt i could have stopped
them that's a bummer died a horrible's
death
didn't mess with your record
well no find out later [ __ ]
well you can redeem yourself right now
this is a really good
may play of the game opportunity here
all right
also you guys just a reminder uh we have
been playing
overwatch all day we've been playing it
since 10 a.m this morning and we will be
playing it until tay passes out or whoa
or gives me the reins
she might
oh we'll do some swappies and
if you guys like what you see
always check back with us we're always
on twitch gamespot you can find us on
gamespot.com
and if you're on youtube please like and
subscribe so you guys can hang out with
us some more
someone needs to kill that pharah
yeah she's doing work
she's harassing the [ __ ] out of you
oh god alt already
what do you typically do against
heavy ranged people like her
try to snipe her i guess myself you're
pretty weak against that yeah
even though i shouldn't be the one
having to do that but
she's two of them
you might have to change characters
that's not true um that's greedy
is it though a little
how about we just kill someone we know
we can kill
it's really easy to
take them out when they
when they're frozen still like that
you're surrounded
nice
that was a great wall oh
no
no oh there was like three alts on you
yeah i know
i don't know if that was the best i'll
find me actually there there's like two
fairs just like hanging out and then you
got the freaking hanzo like chilling at
the top
oh they got the freaking point from that
i don't even feel like we used that many
of our alts
oh good someone widowmaker that's good
that's what they should be doing
so tay you've been you've been playing
for a while you've been playing
you played the
when was the first time you actually
played this game played at blizzcon the
first time
and you played through the whole beta
and now you are here
what have you learned with your time
to not be near reinhardt
um
i don't know like teamwork's very
important obviously composition team
composition is pretty important
i feel like obviously too if if possible
it's a team-based game you want to
communicate
so the voice communication in the game
is pretty good
i also uh think that cynthia was telling
me too if you don't have you know a lot
of people to play with there is kind of
like the um
like looking for group type thing
in for
overwatch as well
yeah i think that something to be said
that's underrated in
in this game
is moving players around changes the
game
dramatically um i think
naturally when you play a game like this
uh you want to do damage and the more
damage you do or the more people you
kill you think you're doing a great job
but you could be doing
actually more
help for your team by moving them around
and getting them out of
the area they want to be in i can
actually oh man that was great that was
good work good teamwork
you can get oh man it's okay we won
give you a big face punch right at the
end i know you shot me play the game no
i died may the game i could have got
play of the game play the game i failed
miserably
it's hard i feel like you always get see
the same people and play the game um
actually that's not him normally i
normally see
reaper bastion
sometimes genji
yeah
hot
sometimes uh
junkrat
yeah because he gets the tire it's a lot
of most of them are coming from like
triple kills and stuff like that
someone said symmetra wipes the floor on
this map
uh that last map yeah
um
she can't i mean like symmetra's like
supposedly one of the highest
like winning percentage uh like support
characters so
like
i wouldn't be surprised because
teleporter is so key and you know if
you're on defense
uh you know her turrets are very good
there's you know you can put six of them
and she's just really like solid all
around she can give shields to everyone
and so i wouldn't be surprised if that's
the case
you know yeah i would tell you that's
probably where i'm the weakest i feel
like i've made an effort to play
the characters all by this point so i
have at least familiar knowledge with
each character but the maps i'm still
kind of blind to some of the maps i
still find little
escape routes that i'm not familiar with
and for some reason i always get sent to
the hollywood map i don't know why that
is i've only got to play that one once
dude i got it like 80
last night and it's my least favorite
map
i think visually because it's got like a
lot of like ugly cars in it and stuff
hey man some of those are like probably
like future teslas and stuff like that
they do look like future teslas um
yeah i mean like if like some sound
device even for like that you were kind
of like alluding to in a way it's like
you want to be able to play like one of
each character type you know so that if
you're
you know if your group is missing like a
healer or a tank or you know an
offensive character that you could kind
of fill out the roster so that
you know you you have some variants in
your play but you know you're always
going to gravitate towards a couple
characters and
you know i would say start off with like
you know four or five that you feel
comfortable comfortable enough with
spree you know
in total in terms of like all the
different
variations and you should be pretty set
to go and then you know definitely hone
in on what you want to do there's like a
bastion and freaking junkrat like
chilling up top we're going to try to
flank them
this is probably going to be in vain but
we're going to try it
because you know go big or go home yolo
we'll see i don't know where the oh
there's the bastion so this is what we
knew he was going to be there oh he's in
the wrong position
die
all right that's what you want to do as
reaper you want to get
you want to just kill him i'm amazed
that you survived that he had the
complete advantage on you yeah well i am
i am the reaper you are the reaper hold
on goob after this
next game we just got a triple we got a
triple without using our q
that's pretty good we gotta gotta hold
off
oh wow the widowmaker's so far away
we're gonna try to elude her
hopefully she's not looking this way
she's like oh crap uh oh oh bastion
do you see any fashion you can hear him
that was the tough one i was late on
[ __ ] you're kind of using them as a
as a spy almost you're kind of trying to
like get on their side and not take them
out from behind right now yeah i'm
trying to flank them i'm trying to get
over there disrupt them so that they're
not really focusing on the payload
that's how i like to play reaper now
that might not necessarily be how you
always want to play reaper because you
don't need like that far from your
teammates but i mean
it did help us get the payload like all
the way over here the freaking
widowmaker's up there
i don't i might be able to teleport
right next to her she's like oh no the
pharah pushed her off
but we do have a tracer so she's kind of
filling that role too
so
what would you say about
the reaper's ability to escort the
payload though as opposed to just going
off on your own like right now you're
playing him like tracer right like
you're going off to take out snipers to
take out
uh
just to
flank people from behind as you're
saying but like what about
like clearing the objective
um that's i mean we could stay near the
payload i just have not
just because i'm great
oh are you worried about your stats no
you won't play the game yeah i won't
play the game do you have a different
animation for play the game no i wish i
had the one yeah
her
death
my stupid laugh
he's so evil
freaking discord orb he saved all of his
balls and through the match i should
have just shipped away here i was trying
to man-mode him you know
did you it's okay i'll cue to get a
queue to get a play of the game maybe um
no but oh my god the way i look at it
too is like you're right like depending
on the situation but
are
our payloads just moving forward so much
that i can afford to kind of play that
way
no i like it like we've discussed
earlier you don't always want to just
wander on your own but
you know like the other team is already
upset because oh you could jump in there
yeah i can't right now because of
zenyatta's old
i just got discorded which is like super
annoying
it's a nice way to harass
your beyond just altered or something
oh you got a nice little health orb
there
you're not invincible you can still get
killed that is correct i'm getting
killed right now
stop it
stop that zenyatta so it's an
interesting
tactic to do it
to use your alt in a place
where you can do a lot of damage but not
die right away
get the most out of it
you see so many play the games with
reaper
you might still kill me here
nice
knowing where the health is is pretty
important too like this torbjorn like
obviously just didn't care
you're that's again your map knowledge
what's that bastion's doing because he
shouldn't be in like this form because
he's not gonna win
he's not
he's oh there he
i hear you he's preparing
i think he's preparing his body
oh she should probably take him out
there she is probably gonna
see
no i don't have the range
from the shadows
i'm gonna go hopefully get up play the
game work with tracer
look at him he's not in his other form
again
i don't know
i don't think he's thinking this through
i don't think so
no i almost never see him in his upright
position unless he's like freaking out
it's weird to see him like that
that's true
i feel bad for these guys it's like
their whole team's not watching their
backs i've ran around their base
so many times already
almost got snipped dang it might be time
is it though i mean you've had that ult
for a while now
i don't even know if their team's going
to come out anymore
i'm serious over
hurry just run in there and use it okay
i got him
i got him you heard the
play of the game
maybe it could have been the triple from
earlier
yeah that's right dang
boy all right let's see it because you
didn't use your alt this will probably
be it was that triple kill this is going
to be one of those few and far between
moments where reaper gets played the
game for being reaper
good job we
had some [ __ ] lord on our team
i didn't even get any medals uh well
what does that do
like i know the accolades are nice but
like what do they result in nothing you
know pride e-peen
you know
i'm gonna leave and get some people in
all right
he's already invited he's already
invited where's um
chain gun
chain gun pope
let me invite you should we get randolph
ramses yeah let's do it current eic
game spots editor in chief hey turn off
the stream i don't want randy damn it
you can mute him
about to remove him from the group
you're about to get
you're about to get out of it
there you go can't hear you guys
whatever you're trying to relay to me is
not gonna work no it's still in
damn it
really
got rid of it i thought all right let's
just kill every in-game voice thing
all right how about now mary
sounds
sounds like there's no audio at all yeah
you turned it off didn't you
there's game audio really game audio is
up
oh it's just very it's very it's very
you know
can you hear mccree smoking and thinking
about tranquility his life
um
what do you think he thinks about i
don't know i'm crazy
but he's a banff
you know so uh-huh
i don't know
yeah whoops my mic was open no [ __ ]
oh man ed thinks i'm an underrated
personality cool oh wait we gotta wait
for ed
i agree gotta wait for bay
no you're bae
you're tabe
please may oh yeah
nearly got booted
that's right gaby survived
for now
where is this e dwarfs elves in
how do you say his name
ed
is it his like handle
uh
yeah number one
who's your um number one most played
hodor um
it would probably be mercy because i've
been playing a lot of
support
recently
to be fair
medic was one of my favorite roles in tf
too so it seemed like a natural
blend i think she
i think mercy is
such a
a tide turning character
where
she
you're not doing a lot of damage in fact
she's incredibly useless for damage but
her ability to revive people changes
games
frequently and i think that that there's
a lot of value in that so i certainly
don't mind
we'll get you on there in like
a couple more games you wanna we can
keep swapping back yeah i'll do some
mercy i'll do some mercy plays um i
think she's fun and
uh you also get to fly around she's like
the most interesting in terms of like
being able to float around and then i
think my other favorite would probably
be
junk junkrat and that's just because
his mobility is really fun and you can
use his
uh items not just to hurt other people
but to like propel yourself up over the
the game and
to new areas i think that's really neat
i like mobile characters i've been
playing bastion a lot
um diva
you just like to fly huh i do i like to
i like to be mobile i think being slow
pisses me off for some reason
oh we're defending okay uh all right
gotta get that play of the game with me
i'm gonna force oh we got all right
someone's playing tank there you go
uh team toaster said may and lucio were
he's most played in the beta
i
i really like lucio as well i love i
think lucio's one of the um kind of like
one of the most fun supports because you
can kind of still heal everyone right
while still shooting your gun you know
so like you don't have to just be
healing now i do find healing with mercy
still fun but it's just you get to
constantly move around you're not
looking for people necessarily that's
like all she does right like she's
either
she's either
uh healing or she's amplifying their
damage she's not actually executing
damage on her own on turret
me and uh cj fan we'll just we'll just
uh we'll pull up here and we'll regret
it
a good spot for people that don't know
is you can go up onto this boat for may
or for anyone i don't think i can get up
here i think
oh or can i dang
i should have put tour bjorn up here
damn it
that's things you gotta think about yeah
well we're thinking about them right now
oh yeah
laser head was like you like playing
bastion but you hate being slow that's a
really that's true that's a huge
difference um i i love movements i love
movement so much um but i've been
playing bastion because he's a really
fun heavy um and his tank form is really
interesting but i agree
it pisses me off when i'm slow which is
why i like lucio because he makes me
faster
guy here
oh he's gonna kill you oh that was close
and the heel the ice heels you need to
take out their mercy
how is he back already uh we're i'm
right next to the spawn point i gotta
get out of here dang just taking him out
twice in a row i had to piss him off
that's the point
paul may all day
oh they got a bastion like showing in
the freaking room now
that's smart
oh it's uh
you try to reflect that this is this oh
man come on
he well he got killed by you twice in a
row
can you tell
when diva
jump riddle oh watch out
and that tire is so brutal and you can
only tell through audio so you gotta be
like really paying attention to that
fine snip sip
no i froze them all kill em all
i don't know if they did
uh we're being jerks
i should have just stood on top of that
actually damn it
do you think they're going to continue
to nerf characters as we go on i want to
be surprised if there's character
balances like i don't know i don't feel
like any character needs huge ones i
mean you can argue that some need maybe
a little bit but who knows you know
blizzard's always been really good about
um
cookie riot says
amazing that's good i know
please keep the
may puns continue the may puns or the
tape
yay get her
she
is oh it was so close
i should have saved myself instead i
really just wanted to kill the mercy
i was really close i know
that's unfortunate no we're giving up
the point
you hear the tire yeah you can hear it
from a mile away
and you can shoot the tire down which is
really nice i wonder can you freeze the
tire i think it probably just explodes
if you freeze it enough
oh there's a diva oh you're you're too
far away
one more
oh that guy genji
i'll fight genji
not afraid of him
we got some sight here
what
elite nugs
oh my god i'm the nugget king here
i didn't know you could even make that
claim
i'm the nug king
i assume we're discussing chicken nugget
oh what the heck
can you shoot this
does the alt fire do more damage when
they're frozen or do you just use it
because you get more control and you can
get the head shot guaranteed yeah that's
exactly the reason why it's just because
you know you're going to get the
headshot
i just use it from medium to long range
like i said i try to snipe widowmakers
with my icicle gun
team toaster says he always calls
uh
toby toblorn toblerone baby toblerone
his name is elusive to me as well
that was great he tried to alternate
punched him in the face uh brandon asks
is this game much better than battleborn
are they two very different games is it
better to get both
uh that's a great question
we have been doing a lot of discussion
on the differences between these games
and the truth is
they are so different it is very
difficult to compare them
get out of there today
um you're going to get very different
experiences out of both because
battleborn is almost more of like a
co-op campaign style game
where you're playing it in conjunction
with your friends online
and you're working together to finish a
campaign so different than
competitive online play that you get out
of this game
junkrat's suicide bombs
but i had to play the game oh that's
mike mchardy is reviewing this for our
site if you guys are interested in
seeing our review of
overwatch
please stay tuned uh it will be going
live tomorrow morning in fact i know
he's already finished writing it and
we're literally editing the video review
as we speak
uh i know the score
i'm allowed to tell you that
look at you
anyway i would check back tomorrow
morning
i think it goes live probably like
really early tomorrow but it's gonna be
great so i'm excited
to see what people react to it i mean
it's out so you guys can always
check it for yourself
uh battleborn was reviewed by scott
and he
really liked uh battleborn by the way as
well i thought he already reviewed
battleborn i thought he gave it
oh no i think he already did
pretty sure
and he really liked it he said a lot of
good things about it especially the
campaign co-op
i won't tell these guys to stop being
greedy this is how we lost the first
point
too far up uh someone asked if they
should buy this game they're not really
into fps's probably not because that's
the only thing there is with this
oh they're flanking us
watch out for the tire it's gone
you've been frozen
i mean you can always try
like
i play fps's like i played a lot of like
oh man i can't believe she called her
mech back already
no she got revived oh i see
oh she's doing her all together
die for real this time
we're good we're good
um like i played a lot of tf
that's a kill but i don't know like how
how many more fps's i play all the time
but this was like a different one it's
got a lot of different mechanics to it
and if you're not in
fps's you don't have to play it like one
you don't have to play this like
counter-strike or
um call of duty you can play this
you can be a healer like i was like like
play support and just help your
teammates out you feel incredibly
involved in the game and have a really
good time that was so greedy on my part
damn it
i wanted to keep freezing him to punch
him and then the junk rat showed up what
a jerk
it was my
mistake is there
oh
digitalistic said maybe you'll get play
of the game
maybe not
um
did my all not go off seriously oh god
maybe can it get destroyed i feel like
it can
i don't know that was weird
that's a shame though oh gather
man that's so quick when did they have a
hanzo maybe he changed
how dare he play overwatch the way it's
supposed to be played
oh there's a totally dude up there
may the 24th be with you all right
that's a stretch but i like it
oh my god that was such a far hit that
was incredible
good work
you're watching tay currently do work
that guy's really ambitious with like
i feel like they're not going in
together they're going in they're like
walking in one at a time
oh no you got a sniper oh no no no
there's a genji thanks for using the alt
after vicky
jesus
kicking you from the group just kidding
easy easy
now i think we got it
uh yeah it looks pretty good for you
guys play of the game if they have any
push it's now oh god
time for play it's still time for two
it was a nice ice wall too actually
again breaking them up not allowing them
to all be in at once
so you can take them out one at a time
using your ice
at the perfect moment right before you
die to re-heal up
i'm so impressed
that's gotta be playing the game [ __ ]
you did that's may come on all day
come on hey one time come on mary one
time believe in it here we go here we go
let's see let's see let's see how good
it is i've seen some pretty [ __ ] play
the games this looks it looks promising
from behind oh
now you can't fight that
team what but it was my ice wall that
stopped it from going in oh
you here give yourself an accolade if
you feel so
no do it to yourself no no no no no no i
can't i already voted i i'm not i can't
do that i only do that if i'm like one
away
i had more eliminations than ed come on
you know what i can do is i can um
i'm not watching the stream don't trash
talk
i can't what i can do is just go watch
the highlight
which one was it on temple of anubis oh
my god
watching your own highlights
no no i want to see it no
commit to it i think it takes everyone
out though
yeah it doesn't matter
too late we're going into a skirmish
that's a pretty good mate game though
that was a great may game
oh you want to play lucille
i don't know i'll play one more and then
we'll swap you all right swap the hot
seat
i don't know who else did they not play
today i'm trying to think of character
trying to play characters they didn't
really show off today but i mean i hope
i remember my password
oh you can play on my account and level
me up no i want my own loot crates
loot boxes i call them loot crates
because they yeah seem similar i bet
loot crate's enjoying that
probably
um
who does the chat want to see
genji i'll be doing a lot of supports
when i play because i enjoy it so yeah a
lot of people have said genji
i'm seeing a lot of genji's the genji
owner team though double gange
get genj
i'm so bad again you can also
oh
we'll see
a lot of times
look it's your favorite map
ugh look how gross the cars look
i don't i'll admit i don't have the
skills for genji but i'm still not into
it i'll play him you've got lots of
skills i think maybe you just haven't
put the time into them that you need
yeah exactly character familiar
familiarity is not there for for me for
genji what are the game's requirements
well i can tell you right now i was
playing it with the new
graphics card you that i just put in and
it wasn't even that great it was like a
660. and it was running
1080 on medium that's not bad and it was
fine yeah i uh 60 60 frames for sure
i tried to i tried to stream on it and
it chugged so bad so
it's like
yeah and i think yeah i i had to put it
on low to stream it and i think i had to
put on 720. but the thing about this
game is
that
you don't lose too much right like when
you went down to medium or low i didn't
i personally didn't feel like i lost
that much i don't know about you though
um
like was it notice it like noticeably no
because the art style
smartly has been made
with that in mind and i really uh
appreciate that this is the kind of game
where frame rate matters visuals
uh i turned down um
uh all shadows i just turned them off
uh there was something else that you can
turn off that just like really helps
your frame rate stay good and that helps
a lot
um
so the beauty of it is if you don't have
a really high-end pc
you can absolutely lower your settings
to pretty much minimal and it still
plays fine you won't be missing that
much because of the art style so kudos
to them uh your specific setup i don't
know it'd be hard to know like
without testing it myself
what do i do there i don't think i can
do anything wall climb
no don't put myself in the position to
get hooked i guess yeah i suppose
um
do you know what the frame rate is on
the ps4
i don't know if it's locked at 60.
oh god
i haven't even touched this game on
console
uh i just don't know if i could play it
i wonder if you can deflect a hook
that'd be pretty insane
does anyone know if you can deflect the
hook that'd be good to know actually
what's the question for the chat if
anyone else knows can you deflect hooks
i don't think you can this damage just
tickles freaking reinhardt
what is this
so your best against shooter
mama wow he just yelled so he's a melee
so you're probably weakest against a
heavy melee because you're also melee i
can't believe you just did that man
you're probably better against um like
you're really good against bastions
right because you can deflect
so when he shoots at you you can deflect
those bullets back at them
whereas
a melee character you're probably going
to get the old squisharoo
nice
oh it ends it doesn't keep go okay no it
doesn't keep going how long do you think
it lasts i've seriously played genji
once so a good
you can combo your moves right you hit
deflect and you shift up really close to
them and then you melee the [ __ ] out of
them i was being really greedy because
the the shift like if you get it if you
get eliminations with it you get uh
resets you learned a valuable lesson
nice that was the thing i got the audio
cue that's good
we need to who got
no where did he go
he's playing him much better than me oh
no he's gonna murder my teammates
uh yes he might
you also have your alt though so you
could do the same thing you could find a
way to like kind of
get shot in the head well she's killed
you twice that's cheap floozy
this is great genji
gameplay upset for losing badly a cheap
floozy yeah
but she kind of isn't all right
all right
all right do we just bust our all just
to kill her
i mean i don't know oh god
do it
you don't get greedy use it oh my god no
this is not a good time you're gonna die
that's it i should have shown backseat
i just didn't feel confident having to
fight a tank half-life and burning my
all right here i am i maybe could have
killed them i at least killed the widow
so when junkrat's tire gets shot
it's like someone
punched you in your heart because you
spend up all these
time earning that you just
blow it socks
do it
nice do work
stab them in their faces
no i deflected it
well
that's still pretty good how's the
youtube like in my genji
oh it's going fine oh yeah you think so
in fact you were doing so much work as
may i think people were like
play somebody you're not as good at and
now you're you're seeing this i don't
know i think you're being too kind
um i completely understand getting it on
the same console as your friends because
this is a game you want to play with
your friends i have a lot of friends
that have this on pc which is why i got
it on pc i agree with you i play uh
rocket league on ps4 and it's on every
console and i have to play it on ps4
because that's where my friends are at
so get it where your friends are at
because you're gonna have way more fun
playing this
you just come in
i think i need to do more like
ed no
um you also know you can like
your your right click right to
for what oh you had to fan it out
to like do the spread the spread attack
oh he's high nooning
all right we got 21 24 seconds to make
okay
nice
take him out
how did he not die yet
because he's a tank
i'm amazed
no
it's a shame the other genji is doing
work oh thanks
hey
you know what makes me feel like crap
when i play widowmaker
what's that another widowmaker i see
because if we have a sniper off she will
almost always win
we should erase this game from the
history okay
uh
deleted
just kidding it's on the internet
forever okay we're gonna play on the
opposite side now and
we'll make it we'll make it happen you
got it man you gonna who are you gonna
play who would you say besides may
all day
is the person that you do work with uh i
do work with reaper you saw that earlier
i did see reaper i'm a decent soldier 76
but anyone could be decent i guess
that's soldier 76.
um
i like junkrat
uh decent with pharah i'm afraid of
hanzo as well and i'm afraid of
i'm afraid of several characters that i
think are
complicated to the point where they
they
make me uncomfortable but i just feel
like i just need way more work with them
before i feel confident
see that's not a good sign if well six
eliminations is pretty poor one mm-hmm
but two i
was like my second or third time playing
gen d so our team definitely needed more
dps
um i was actually
really struggling
with tracer uh because she's so fast
that when i zip
i don't know where i am and then i have
to collect my bearings by the time i zip
three times around the map i don't know
where i am oh man look at that freaking
skin
you don't have this one no you have that
origin pack
same shame you're
what
smart man yeah he looks good
she looks good here we'll try we'll try
tracer i don't think too many people
play tracer today no i don't think so i
think she's a fantastic character and i
really like her um she's probably like
weak for me in the sense where i
i feel like my eyes can't catch up
also i think you need incredible map
understanding with her because her
entire job is to get places that other
people
didn't expect her to come from
so it's all about like
really
being aware of map
being tracer on defense could be a
bad idea you she only goes forward right
like she can't go up
uh you can kind of like
mini like so let's see if we can
no not really not really but you can get
she's not vertically mobile yeah but you
can close like gaps or distances so like
you might be able to get over oops as i
say you might be able to get across the
way like if you used all three would you
say you're a good tracer but i've seen
good tracer players and i find them
incredible because you can do that yeah
you can get
so much speed and agility with her and i
think they're she's a really impressive
character when you master her
uh i am not there yet nah she's uh she's
a pretty difficult one um
because her you know her gun
you have to be within a reasonable range
all right let's see it
recorded already
oh did you melee i did but he picked up
the heel
which is rather unfortunate that is
unfortunate that was your heel
should have killed him
i like your responsibility
oh you're gonna go for the flank eh
you shouldn't be hiding in here
nice
on the point though which is kind of a
problem
that's all right
come out of there you
ice queen
i feel like
it must be pretty defeating to come out
of here
to be in your ice block knowing that
you're only going to totally die
yeah well that's the one thing that's
why you got to try to like use her shift
and stuff to like kind of get out
get someone behind you
yeah
dude my guns are so weak nice
you're still doing work with them else
you have your alt dude you can uh tag a
enemy with your bomb
nice
that feels so
that's such a good thing to do
so rewarding
look luckily i didn't miss it as you
said i was like uh i hope i get that
you know because if you're really quiet
you can slowly just calmly hear the
other player go oh [ __ ]
die [ __ ]
oh she's still alive
no that's cheating
she got a health pack
so will i
i'm guessing she's going to hang out oh
she's still there
typically
they're encouraged to move
she's this time
i took her health too
oh you missed that's okay
you can't win them all
thanks mary
getting some hot tips from the chat sick
that um armor negates five damage for
every hit
so
she wouldn't be as good at people who
have inner armor like diva and rain
because
you have to take down their armor by the
time you do that they've already done so
much work they're probably going to kill
you on a one-on-one yeah i definitely
want to get those uh squishies right
that's right europe you're you're all
about killing snipers and health uh
supports basically is your role you got
it
get them
now go out there and be somebody
no
no that was a good face off so low i
should have just freaking blew right by
him he charged his orbs for me
he sure did mother effort he charged his
orbs for you
such a good run
does she get her health back when she
rewinds it depends on when you rewind it
and stuff
so
yeah it you get the health back that you
had
at the beginning of your wind right so
if you
are at like
a tenth of your health
for 10 seconds and you rewind 10 seconds
you still only get that much health
so you have to use it timely oh you're
so smart
did i miss
it's a lot shorter how are they not
knowing you're there
i don't know
if you were reaper you would have like
cleaned up being behind people like that
it's hard with the whole group
because you don't do any spray
damn you're doing great
do work today i did
i done did it done work
here have this
play of the game give me the play of the
game you believe it might that last that
last hold right there was pretty good
hey girl hey girlfriend
yeah i was that like five kill
was good you're behind all of them and
then for whatever reason oh they got
distracted with that other reinhardt so
they didn't
they didn't come get you
dang oh you even did more you did more
than that come on man i killed those two
too it's not like plays of the game it's
yeah it's not tell you the game
oh my god
what day of the game
yeah that's a pretty good one
well
wait are you wanting to
uh we could for a little bit you're
gonna have to go back
because you're
all right come on what you gotta believe
how are we gonna do this we should keep
i have no idea seats too we'll keep the
seats too oh really you gonna swish
around just spin around all right oh you
should log out too and then reinvite
whoever you want
all right it's like i'm not friends with
any of your friends
i almost lost the
mice
oh wait we gotta go back to camera hello
um thank you guys for tuning in to the
second part of the marathon run here uh
this is uh me and mary my name's eric
that's mary of course
and just want to say thank you guys for
tuning in of course and um we're
probably gonna play for at least another
hour and um you know please like and
subscribe you know to youtube and or to
gamespot and whatnot and again follow
twitch and all that stuff so really
appreciate you guys being here joining
in she got in she
she won the first game that was the
password game
and
you know
we're gonna get to probably see some
mercy and some other characters that she
likes to play i'm gonna grab my water i
play a lot of support just so you don't
knock it over because they make me feel
good about myself why i mean like if you
like if you like supports that's awesome
not everything
your junk rat's pretty good too
my joke rats are right i'm hit or miss
uh i'm no tay i'm no bae oh you gots to
believe so we'll have to see we'll see
who i got let me see if i can join the
same game
yeah get you can get ed and then you can
see if he can pull anyone else in
come on ed let me in
ooh leader
you're darn right
all right you got your five a little
five stackaroo
um
i hey i like playing support actually a
lot in this game um
it's like normally you know you could
argue that
support is a style of play that
you know some people like most people
don't always like playing support but i
think if anything um in this game at
least for me
i really enjoyed a lot of the support
characters lucio mercy's fun as well and
i'm starting to get into zenyatta yeah
quick play all right here we go
it's so funny how often i'm actually not
the leader i just yeah you just follow
along i ask for invites and then i and
then i do my thing
that's really loud
did you you stopped it yeah i started
stopped it i don't want these ginormous
files sorry we're talking about doing
some hot recordings so we can get some
gameplay up later that's right not only
do we keep records of the matches you
guys are watching right now with me and
eric tay's lovely voice on top but we
also record straight gameplay without
our lovely voices so that we can mash it
into something better
uh we'll probably do like some
highlight reels or some
yeah whatever
yeah was cool you know some play of the
games or just some nice kills or nice
kind of um oh
chris waters mr ctw you need to cancel
that one and then um get back into your
social i think you can do it from that
plus yeah let's see
and then invitations i think at the top
yeah except him so we're gonna get
riverdoge in here all right and now we
do it for real uh no you gotta invite
him though you just accepted him as a
friend oh i didn't even know i wasn't
friends with him yeah he shows how he
feels about me
i don't know he just sent you the invite
or wait maybe he didn't what
is he not logging it how did he
how did that come up so late i don't
know i assume he's not in the he's not
in the group
chris you have 30 seconds to log on come
on chris
hmm
come on maybe just
do i haven't
i wish i had any loot boxes why don't
you um
buy hot 50
uh
give me your credit card
we can't afford you can't afford it
i can't that much
everything got wiped after the beta
i should redo everybody
uh
all right
so invitation was accepted but no if
he's not there let's just go i thought
he was playing i thought he was playing
too
bro breaking my heart
is he in the chat
uh i don't see him all right tough butts
we're playing he's like genji he's
mysterious
and he's like a ninja you don't know
where he's going to be
so yeah
play as reinhardt mercy combo see if
there's a reinhardt on my channel i
think
goob is
always reinhardt he loves playing him
yeah
goob likes him some reinhardt he likes
um
some junkrat
oh that music
all right so i will get my mercy unlock
i was also thinking i've been
tentatively considering the idea of
cosplaying as
mercy for halloween oh wow but she
is
i i just don't think i got it in me to
like make all that [ __ ] but i did get a
3d uh we have a 3d printer now
maybe you should do uh something about
printing out some wings
you could do your take of wingless
cheap ass mercy you make it with like a
shower curtain no
you know you went into combat
and then you you know
you're coming back like like slightly
defeated or like you know you just got
through a tough battle but it's still
part of the war and they're like you
know you don't have the wings anymore
because it got snapped off or something
i fell from grace dude there's some
crazy fan art there um
that i've seen so far like today someone
linked me that someone's doing some like
dark souls overwatch crossovers it's
pretty crazy
like mercy was like a boss and she was
you know like
one of those like giant type bosses
pretty cool i kind of want to get up
there cosplay is diva the internet
internet might implode though there's
been some diva um
oh and australia internet
not so hot
there's something to be said about that
australia internet
that or he had responsibilities who
knows
so
what you're noting me doing right now is
hiding
oh i got you
so
oh [ __ ]
i'm floating far back i even like to
hide behind a corner if possible because
it kind of like uh goes around oh no
oh man ed back in spectate mode we'll
have to pick him up after this one my
job is to not die no i mean i die that's
gonna happen but
i am i am much more beneficial [ __ ] i
just shifted to my wrong teammate
that's another problem is uh i don't
know if you know this you uh oh [ __ ] you
automatically shift
to the person that you're healing
so
my alt's up yeah uh
oh i'm coming
really
nice way to keep them up oh no chain gun
so you if you want to get away which i
often do i have to stop healing so that
i look at the person that i want to run
to because i've done that before i can
bring them back but i prefer to bring
back more than one if possible it
doesn't always work out like that there
you go oh
i missed it it's okay
don't die though oh i got exploded
exploded
before i even hit the ground yeah
honestly there was like
a half a second where i had my chance
yeah for the double two the dubli um
uh-oh oh we're gonna lose
all right we're gonna lose one piece
here all right
oh my god
someone telling you to do a junkrat
cosplay
junkrat like a lady junkrat or you want
me to like dude it up because i can do
that
i don't know
you lived in australia once it makes
sense right yeah
just be a junkrat are you like is that
an australian thing and you're just like
making fun of australians there's a
question in the chat for you um how do
you know when to boost to heal other
players
uh you see
you get pings for everyone on the map
whether or not they're crit or they need
your help so like right now i can see it
i saw that from a mile away
you can see it through the map which is
a really nice benefit of yeah the
silhouettes but you make the you make
the call
like right now i could be there but i'm
oh [ __ ] i'm being cautious
oh [ __ ] i need to get up there
nope i can't
that's the tough part i gotta get out
i got too close so the issue with me
right now is
i'm in the fire fight and mercy should
never be in the fire fight that's my
mistake i floated away as you saw but
they're going for me because they know
my
they know what i'm doing which is
healing the people that they want to
kill so they want to take me out first
but i will say at the same time though
for sure like if you're playing with a
fellow mercy on your team uh like viggi
up there
was hurt right and her instinct was to
run away but if she had given you line
of sight you could have flew to her and
healed her so it's something to consider
when you're playing with a mercy is to
you know make sure if you see the mercy
that you give her a way to get to you
otherwise she can't heal you so it's
like you can't really ask for heels if
you're not like
presented i can't go in there
don't do it so i'm making the call right
now to run away
um even though i could have jumped in
there and healed them because i know it
would have killed me i think you're in a
tough spot i'm in a real tough he's high
noon
he's not looking at you though so it's
gonna be all right i'm running this way
oh [ __ ] oh that is not a good look
we're in a lot of trouble
they have been all right that was not a
very good game surprise
the payload has reached its destination
uh it destroyed its destination oh man
he's got that freaking evil knievel he
looks so badass that's awesome i wonder
if this play of the game you always
wonder when the play of the game will
have your face in it
no this one this one's your teammate so
she couldn't have sniped you
but
so far i'm not seeing very much play of
the game no that's not oh you got two
all right you got two piece
you want to back out do leave game and
then uh do it somebody else went in yeah
for ed he's spectating so leave as group
oh i went all the way out gg
that's not what i meant it's all good
get ed and then get the rest of them
actually i don't know if i'm
like you're friends with that
i'm friends with ed i don't know about
everybody well
they'll figure it out
this is fine
lucille play lucio i like lucio a lot
yeah he has aoe they're not as strong as
mercy as jack i think if i'm reading
that right is saying
um
but yeah he like i said is more mobile
he can do other stuff he doesn't have to
be directly healing he can heal like the
whole team and stuff like that it might
not be able to join why is that
boom australia joined nas there have
been some random kicks from the like
remember when i crashed and stuff like
that
uh my friend last night was having some
trouble
so where's where's gooberino uh maybe
from the green one that green chat
no
that works too
boom check that friends list uh
play hanzo yeah
roadhog widow
they're all coming in now
i want to add
oh
yeah if you do it at the top you'll do
it oh he's in another party is why
probably they'll all join there you go
uh if you go to your recent players
does that let you in fight oh no it
doesn't i think just friend
let's see
i see
well you do you boo
no
i'll play some
zenyatta later unless marion wants to
play some zenyatta you can play some
zenyatta no that sounds good they want
something they want some widow i'm sure
they do my sniping skills are hit or
miss
i've had that's how i feel too though i
i watched danny snipe and i'm like man
how did i
how did i not
carry over am i joining his group or am
i inviting him to my group you can join
his group and then get ed
if he's already got a group
now added
all right here we go there you go
and vicki will just have to play on
herself that's fine
on her own all right goob is leader
all caps to show that i mean business
yeah internet yelling surprise
gotcha
wow
oh who else oh river doge
trying to convince him to jump yeah yeah
he's definitely queuing up we're gonna
get some sick ctw hopefully waters does
work as well so he would be a really
good person to support what is up like a
wasp
and also where are we at with time
we're at like 4 45 oh we're good i'll
play a couple games and then we'll
probably switch back and tails do some
more work before we go home uh this is
all a part of our overwatch
all-day marathon stream thanks for
joining us loot box oh
i'm so sorry for your loss
oh that's so sad that was a
pretty bad box if you guys are curious
what 40 will buy you in this game i'm
pretty sure we have some videos going up
of danny and chris opening up
uh 40 worth of boxes which is 50 boxes
they got
two legendary skins um
they got three oh did they get three and
then yeah and then they had two thousand
coins yeah so then they had enough
credits to buy two more and i think he
bought one about pharaoh one
so
and and they got some you know epics and
and also some rares obviously
um
i didn't get to see it all uh so to each
their own so if that's the case then
it's like eight dollars a legendary skin
because you can't currently buy you know
the skins that you want unfortunately
which is kind of like one of the
complaints that people have but it's a
gamble right yeah even though they got 2
000 they barely got there the last box
they got because understand he had
earned one so he had 51 boxes on the
50th box he opened he got like 25 and it
was enough credits to get him to 2000.
like he scraped by
uh so
it's very likely you won't get that much
because they got like a giant pile of
coins on they got 500 and one pull
remember that
yeah that was really yeah that was a
legend you get 50 or 100. yeah that's
still like legendary gold legendary or
whatever yeah legendary coins and again
another all right i'll play one more
mercy and i'll probably play lucio a
little bit do it uh the other thing that
peeved me a little bit was just like oh
i got a legendary oh it's 500 coins and
yeah you can argue that you can buy a
bunch of stuff with 500 coins but it's
not a legendary skin like it would have
been nice to been able to get a thousand
gold for that and be like yeah i get to
pick the one i want to do instead
ultimate legendary right is like we're
going to give you enough gold to pick
what you want even in all these boxes
you spend 40
that's no chump change
like that is a lot of money for me to
gamble
gamble and hope that i get what i want
um i mean they're all like really rad
skins but the the truth is like i only
play a certain amount of types of
characters like i don't want to spend 40
bucks and get like a bunch of really rad
may skins like i want my i want the
skins i want i want the skins i want
i understand i mean
it totally makes sense and in a way if
you think about it
like
man i i must be really unlucky because
in a way it sounds like
you should be getting almost a legendary
skin every like close to 10 boxes and
i have not gotten a legendary skin yet
that's a bummer i have also not gotten
one you're and you're like what 12 right
now yeah you're 12 so from there but
like i said it's all rng because my some
of my friends that i was playing with
last night they did get um like one or
two legendary scenes i think like
uh adam
got like three and he got like two of
the same skin or something which was
like insane he got a sweet zarya like
the russian
zarya oh man that's so sick and then uh
cj fan who we were playing with earlier
who's a christopher robin and um twitch
chat he freaking got a may
uh
getty skin sniped and i was so salty it
looks so good i'm gonna heal up
yeah you gotta watch out for that sniper
i think she's aiming for me
oh she's got a tracer too tailing you
guys ooh this is not a good look i know
i gotta run where my peeps at yeah you
need someone to fly to ooh
i think your team got wiped so great job
everybody here we go
test and now we're doing it for real
come here
oh no chris
i'm so used to seeing reinhardt as goob
that i actually didn't know what to do
trace
crap crap
you're fine
no i'm not i just gotta find someone to
fly to i don't have anyone
his name is chris
there you go
you're my boy
you're my boy chris
it's funny that you can still heal him
through the ice wall uh i need to
oh that's
oh wow i almost got behind that wall you
lived through the tracer bomb
i flew through it
i got killed on the wall
dishonorable
dishonorable okay i need a i need to
double check something everyone keeps
talking about like the pricing of the
game and i keep i know for sure it's 40
and 60 on pc but i don't know what it is
on console
like a lot of people are saying it's 60
for there's no like 40 version of
overwatch let's see no there is right
i don't know it is it is uh
it is 60.
i'm trying to fly somewhere safer
do a double revive there
um for anyone who's curious of like when
i know to revive
oh [ __ ] i'm in danger i shouldn't have
crossed that area that's a really
dangerous opening wide open yeah that's
where like the
widows and whatnot are yeah i'm just
like asking for trouble when you when
you stream like when you're flying in
between there but
the double revive is nice
i'm getting icicles okay so yeah i guess
it is 60
for uh console origins and whatnot
yeah
and then the only way to get at 40 is
digital pc only gotcha yeah it wasn't
yeah i think the consoles are you're
getting the packs yeah well you're
getting the uh origin crack yeah
there's no other version
kill that tracer i'm getting
so i could see that as like a harder
thing whoa why the alt
boob
may is disappoint
all right so i'm gonna hide behind this
corner and hope that a tracer doesn't
come after me
this is a tough one like to break if
like i might have to change characters
pretty soon yeah well that is a luxury
in this game oh crap
you like that all electronics
uh amazon fifty dollars for the ps4
version okay not bad not bad
heroes never die
they never die
oh crap
i think it's worth 60 dollars if you
have um oh my god sniped out of the sky
like a dead bird
uh i think it's worth it if uh a you
have
like if you like the game obviously and
b especially if your friends play i
think it's a very fun team-based game oh
like i have a great time even when i
lose which you'd think that would like
break your heart but like i i have a
wonderful time
regardless this is such a fun game
i'm with you come on girlfriend
i'm a man my name is hanzo
i'm coming i'm coming to you
right through the the trailer
the the pickup the forklift
they found me i thought i was sneaky
you got killed by drool that's all right
that's the worst nobody wants to die to
drool
true
oh they're attacking the point oh crap
we really need to take it too i
shouldn't have died there i guess you
could say you should never die anywhere
uh but especially right when you have 30
seconds left before
hopefully they didn't die yet
all right that's good who's the other
one on the uh okay that's good as well
oh crap he did not get anyone with it
oh i heard a widow make her shot just
like whiz bye back up back up
ah the tracer is always in my freaking
face that's what she's supposed to do i
know and she's doing a great job but the
truth is is like
when i'm doing my job i gotta have like
a little bit of uh we lost we have to
have a little protection from
tracers or snipers because they'll just
eat me alive
yeah i mean it's up to the person you're
healing to of course take care of the
tracer or try to right because you're
not really going to do it i mean you
could switch to your pistol but it's not
going to be effective you're going to
stop healing so
um
yeah maybe i should play somebody i can
play with damage do it
junk it up still a support or something
a couple head shots
so i did 24
of the team damage which says i like
help you're healing yeah yeah but i feel
24 yeah that's a good amount of quarter
you can always do better
that's the beauty of the game all right
let's play lucio
lucio
lucia
uh wants me to wants everyone to know
his laptop faded to black and crashed
oh no
he's trying to see if his laptop can
handle playing overwatch because he's
about to go on like a mini vacation
learning but he doesn't want to be
without overwatch somebody which makes
sense that tracer hates my guts and i
agree that tracer
was out for blood
that tracer kicked my ass
there are certain match-ups that are
meant to be right like
aussie and now there's a bastion which
is pretty good with
the reinhardt bashing combo is pretty
strong
but
my
lucio is good for this combo because he
can speed these people up
and there's value in that as well
so all right so what i got these like
sick little
attacks
yep do a little bit of damage that way
my shift changes to a healing
instead
and then i can
heighten my attacks
with my
e
oh it's uh that one does like my
amplifier that one that gives you more
speed and then the other one gives you
more healing
so it just depends on what i want yeah
all right this is looking pretty
promising
hiding in the corner
amplifying my dudes this is my job oh
yeah they're gonna do a smart he
reflected the bastion
chocolata nice
sweet tunes equals sweet hp oh yeah
let's bump the jams bump the gems philip
chan saying raise the volume oh a little
sniper oh don't don't peek again you
don't want to get very silly sightset
[ __ ]
actually i saw that coming from a mile
away and i was like distracted
watch you're going to see me stand still
like somebody's hurting me and then i
get killed
that was tough it was a tough spot to be
in
mars mulder asking he can buy three
games at his local store he definitely
looks like he wants to pick up uncharted
4 and dark souls 3 but should he get do
more overwatch that's a tough call such
a tough call it's a tough one
um man i
i should have taken her on
um
i think you'll get more out of this
in the long run
but those other two are decided because
doom's single player campaign is is
really really good that's not a bad
proposition by adam saying get to four
and then trade it for overwatch oh
that's cool so my honest
my honest uh advice to you would be
crap get out of the way i'm getting
killed here uh
if you are into campaigns doom is a
freaking great campaign yep and you will
get more enjoyment out of that
if
if you want
oh my god if i die before i get anywhere
i'm going to be pissed
uh if you're into multiplayer games
then this has value
yeah
oh you guys survived that somehow
yeah all these people need
a shield
so let's make that happen yeah do
multiplayer is kind of like eh it's okay
so if you're looking for a multiplayer
shooter this is the one though for her
at least for now uh
until maybe like a battlefield or
something if you're into the
battlefields
behind you all right
oh wow
oh the the alts are just coming in that
was like three alts in a row ugh
justice reigns from
ver just like horizontal they're really
nice to like
win a game before we end here you can do
it
you must believe
come on guys shoot him tony thank you
i see um
that guy up there oh yeah you know what
i haven't been doing enough
yeah pushing people
away you can do it nice
little soldier action
oh he got revived and didn't realize it
he must have like was drinking some
water like oh [ __ ] i got revived i was
just drinking a nice glass of water and
then went oh [ __ ]
god i'm getting snipes from that corner
i gotta be really careful
i'm gonna stay here and try to get more
points it's more important
to win yeah and we're already we're only
at 76 so if they take the point again
we're gonna lose
that's right make it happen
come get some mother effort
they came and got some
surprise
they got some
all right this is it all right this is
they're gonna contest the point it's the
last stand it's a good thing you got
your alt so i'm gonna wow they didn't
even try i didn't even try what
free win we'll take it i like it
sucka
here we go
yeah if you can rent doom 4 that's not a
bad proposition too it's like a 12 ish
hour game depending on you know it's
it's a really fantastic campaign i can't
say it enough and they're going back to
like classic shooters where you're going
to really enjoy the movement in shooting
whereas like i've played so many i mean
i know a lot of people don't play like
cod or battlefield for the campaign but
i played a lot of those campaigns and
you're basically just shooting you're
going around shooting and shooting and
shooting doom is about movement it's
about running the map it's about running
away and like knowing when to attack and
when when to like move around the map
it's so much fun uh also like they give
you a lot of opportunities for like
easter eggs and little sneak sneaky
things hidden all over the map i think
that's rad i think they don't do that
enough in games
yeah i i mean like i uh really enjoyed
all the guns i got most of the weapon
mods and they're just like really
satisfying to use absolutely the micro
missiles once you get the final like
mastery add-on it's insane you don't
even have to shoot your heavy machine
gun anymore you can basically just shoot
micro missiles that's how awesome it is
i i couldn't agree more it's really
enjoyable die [ __ ] and i
it's such a funny thing to say don't get
snipped i see that little sniffer
oh crap i'm the last of the mohicans
over here don't let them get the point
put him off
i'll play him come on you can do it
there's a lot of people in there
watch out good deal
that's okay tracer yeah hop right over i
will
she's fast but she's dumb as hell
i don't know how you live through that
you run you squirrel
later i'll i'll better you dart you dart
around left and right and then you go
where am i
yeah you got a wall ride oh shoot
somebody's just freaking i think
reinhardt charged off the list no that's
a rite of passage as chris waters says
that is a rite of passage every
reinhardt falls off a ledge
like it's totally understandable
is it though oh he's trying to push me
back did you see that yeah so if you
push people properly you can push them
right off the ledge in this map and it's
really freaking it's such a heartbreaker
oh i tried to push him back
don't snipe me i want to see it um i
pushed him with my right click and i
wonder what that did i guess yeah the
snipe
snipe took me out anyway but i feel like
i didn't hit him enough
it was close
run
i'm harry with her squirrel mlg skills
that's right you like
i hope the team got that too but if not
at least you saved your bacon
fudge there was too many of them i was
really trying to take out
mercy
i almost did it if it wasn't for that
effing mech yeah
that mech
that mech all right i'm back
uncharted 4 does have a multiplayer
sorry
it does but who cares
wow
i'm i'm serious like it's not known for
it it's not like a valuable multiplayer
they got hotline bling dance
yeah sure
i know i'm just wrestling
oh yeah all right get on the point boys
and girls it's a close one oh that lucio
is just hanging out with you guys oh
he's oh did you just punch him off i
sure [ __ ] dead i don't think he died no
way
i didn't see i didn't see the uh i got
to kill that
no you're good i think there's a diva
who needs help
i got you
i love you all
be the audio medic
dude he's such a
such an enjoyable character like
just to hear him talk and
do what he does i really enjoy like
listening to him
it's like pump up the jams guys let's do
this
oh hello
oh how did that i didn't it didn't even
move her at all
but my alt is almost
my alt is almost ready so if the shield
can survive well they got to push the
point in two percent or they're gonna
lose that's it like right now bam
w
overwatch
who got play of the game
it was
severe
sever we don't we don't know a superhero
all right it could have could have
killed me he's gonna aimbot aimbot
he did work
oh how did he how come he lives through
that [ __ ] that's a good question
this is the only time where i get my
accolades because you'll never see a
support or a healer like ever get play
of the game you don't know that i've got
always based on kills it's not based on
that that's doing something
i forgot to give accolades justin has uh
gotten someone with mercy revives yeah
um
and i want to say well yeah i guess the
symmetra one was killed and i've gotten
one with zenyatta but that was also
kills so that makes that's fair but you
don't always it it's more likely though
you're right that it it's from kills
though
um all right so
this will probably be
my last and then i'm gonna bring it back
to you and tay's gonna bring us home
okay
let's do it
all right what's support um
i really like lucio i'll do him one more
time sure
um
i'm not as familiar uh symmetra is
actually like pretty complicated
because you have to like
understand where to where the warp
should go and if you don't use them
properly it's like why
yes so yeah
why did you do it at all
she's definitely good for you know
getting people back into action also her
right click on her weapon symmetra this
is is really strong because it goes
through like reinhardt shield and
whatnot
um
but yeah she's
you definitely need to have some
character familiarity otherwise you play
genji like i did and that was just a
terrible scene what goob's gone is there
any of my they all left me even ed left
oh my peeps are gone i'm playing with a
bunch of strangers they're like oh you
got the win all right
see ya
oh my god i have no friends
good luck
geology a lot of people wanted widow
uh
tay how are you how are your widows
widows
not even close i should not have gone
that way
nope how about the hot tub
is there water in there i can't tell
you're like
okay what's the point [ __ ] it's not
great it's okay
take out that guy for trying to flank us
sneaky butt
oh see ya oh no she might be back
if i was her depending on her situation
i have the wrong uh
that's fine get my health on yeah
not my speed although speed is so
underutilized in this character oh
there's a sniper i fear yeah it's very
situational but yeah it's good to get
people back to the point and stuff like
that
um
yeah but that tracer could have like
warped back and made it back or whatever
yeah
i know i'm pushing it i'm feeling a
little frisky i think it's because
we won the last two so i'm getting a
little
watch out don't cry it's coming i hear
it
oh
rip in peace is bastion oh man
you're once a good turret
i'm just doing a little bit of
just pissing people off right now
oh did you see that yep
i'm just tackling
i'm away am i
you're tr you're trapped
heal yourself mary
okay
this map is very good because i'm from
greece trying to shoot me off
you see that yeah i did
greece is just fun in general because
there's so many areas you can punch
people off over like hook people across
and it's really fun
surprise got a present for you he sure
did
[ __ ] don't you know i got heals i got
heals for days
i'm just harassing now because i don't
have anything better to do are they
going to take this point they're trying
nice
did i get that surprised the crap out of
me was it tire yeah it was a tire damn
oh i guess we thought maybe there'd be
more
that's all right it was worth it no
regret
well they got the point though that was
bad on your teammates parts i should
have been the only one you know what we
were like so we've been in there for so
long that we were like we got it
this is true
break it down getting shields
you get a shield oh [ __ ] that's ours i
think and you get a shield
genji gets a shield too everyone gets a
[ __ ]
die
that's good you idiot push there
crap we're gonna get snipes
i'm just gonna hang out
so is the reaper
oh you guys are good
you guys are too
all right
win number one oh
that's fine hit yeah there you go
it was only to goob to no one else
i was to my
to my bff
pump the
jams forgot what the name of that song
is
is that like a space jam it's not a
space jam song no
i know it from jock jams you know oh
yeah jock jams man
those are great that was like an old
that wasn't the original no that's what
i call music
mtv though right uh
or was it just its own thing i think it
was like its own private
oh man they're all the way over there
and they're everywhere yeah they're
attacking that gun is a bad person damn
it
surprise he sure did i
i think it's always depressing when they
hit you once and i wasn't able to do
anything like i dodged him but i
couldn't do anything about it yeah
but i'll speed back there
here we go
back in the
into the fray
let's get some heels going
okay
oh god i'm all alone fell over
come on dude
where are my people up coming back on
this morning please
we need to get in
lucio and lucio crime
oh that guy is dead
sure
i shouldn't be in here this is a
possibly bad look
harass
i should have told you to heal yourself
just realize you're on speed
i you know i was on speed trying to be
like quick and movie but i'm in the i'm
in a nowheresville so yeah it's not
smart
all right let's try this again
we're at 52 percent and losing
yeah it'll be 1-1 and then it'll be the
well the big well
map love that map so they've been
careful you're by yourself where is
everybody they got team wiped all right
it's probably because we didn't have a
healer uh i think that's a genji alt
and you got a shield
[ __ ] there's some coordination going on
i could hear it from a mile away there's
not a lot i can do
chop chop all right i'm coming back
they all get team wiped again i'm in
trouble oh you got four right now
you guys have a chance if you guys can
push one now
go go go
[ __ ] uh junkrat i hear it
crap i'm taking so much [ __ ] damage
sorry that's all right i mean the thing
is still the interesting thing about a
junkrat is so good in here because
you're just in a pool of his own like
grenade yeah
i think this is going to be it for us
we'll see
i think you guys you have guys there
though so yeah the interesting thing
about roadhog is he isn't considered a
tank do a lot of work but uh he's like a
weird one especially in a scenario like
this because it doesn't have anything to
shield nice alt
um to really shield damage for you like
the rest of you guys
but
oh god he just broke it down too
and that's a jumper at all ain't got
nobody though i think i think you're in
trouble though
high noon
all those alts are so good in small
areas
because it was really oh the dubli
oh you guys almost had it go go go i
think it's over
yeah it's all right fight for game three
you know game three have the sweaties
uh you don't keep your stuff from beta
or i lost all my loot boxes yep
yeah
offensive tank
reinhardt
you're my first mate
is that how ships work i kind of yeah i
guess
okay
pump the jams
hmm pump the jam pump the jams
um siege toe asking why can you see the
other team through walls uh widowmaker
has an ability that uh tactical visor
that allows her to pretty much have wall
hacks
for like a limited amount of time
double genji on the other team almost
punted him off you you little he's going
to kill me now no he's missing a lot
the fair might kill you though
that's another story
did that diva just freaking ride to her
death i feel like she did
write a passage today right of passage
is it though
he's so close i believe in you oh he's
healing himself
i don't know you kind of look the same
nice job
it took like so long to get that guy
but it's okay did you notice how i
didn't use uh health i use speed so
like the thing i'm doing right now is oh
i'm dying when i'm not using my health
upgrade i am using speed to
whip around them because they have a
really hard time catching me
except for that one bastard
that sniped you or whatever he snipped
me good but we still got the point yeah
that's true
they're contesting right now though
surprise
double dragon the dragon's going through
walls
yeah you just kind of got to see it soon
enough that's this is one of those times
too where um you know if you were on
comms like communication would have been
like hey hanzo i'll watch out yeah and
then you kind of like
have a good idea like i need to get oh
no where am i where are my mates
there you are
no all right i gotta stay
not now damn it
frosty knee except you spelled me wrong
uh i'm getting eaten alive here
also they took the point
yep they're turning the tables they have
turned the top the tables
we flipped those actually
i am always skeptical of an offensive
bastion but i guess it kind of works
here
i guess it's not offense defense well it
didn't work in that way
uh junkrat alt
i'm trying to find it it's coming for
you
surprise i could hear it and i couldn't
do anything about it
that's when you just gotta hope that
like the widow oh see the widow tried
she just missed if she sniped it it
would have died one shot all right we're
losing
gotta make it
maybe that bastion's not working oh you
got pretty lucky to avoid that
monstrosity
where's my team at i don't know but you
guys got to make some plays seriously
big plays let's work together as a team
random strangers that i don't know
oh now it's time to get oh
mccree needs to flashbang like that
pharah and take care of her
all right i give everybody a shield
that's the worst feeling i had that
happened to me so many times last year
last night
how do i nail it i forget uh it's uh f i
think i mount my i mapped mine too i
should not have contested mccree
that's fine he's not oh crap we're gonna
lose that's hanzo i think
what will happen
will team mary find a way to hold out
and come back from being dying down 99.
squirrel
oh i thought she was getting ready for
justice from above that would have been
horrific
oh [ __ ] i'm trapped laytrap
okay may alt may all good to push him
off all right you got the capture the
dream is still alive
get him get it [ __ ]
oh that was very unfortunate you need
that right now
uh where is it i heard it too but i
can't see
it's it in front of your face
all right we actually can't lose this
point for like like any time at all i
don't know what was that guy doing
oh man the junker over the top spash
oh you're
[ __ ]
oh
nice
oh help her finish her off oh yes
great move
i can't follow these people no you
definitely you definitely can
but you did back yourself into that heel
that was good watch out for high noon
i like that all that's good is good
[ __ ] this is a real hot oh yeah see ya
reaper
will this be the
the hold the hot hold
oh he just broke it down but i think he
only broke it down for him and aphara
you can just kill those two
i think their team's gonna respawn
though yeah you're gonna have another
fight on your hands here
gotta hope that they don't have too many
alts die
you can't hit mary she's a squirrel you
can't hit wait you can't see uh i
you know what i mean you can't i
couldn't oh i guess they never contested
the point for me so i should assume you
guys want come back the comeback is call
it a comeback
oh man i got
the shakes the shakes the shakes the
handshakes oh i haven't felt these since
we played rocket league oh
oh
all right
no accolades for mary but i know i did
work it's about it's about the w my
favorite was when i pushed that guy into
the death yes reaper went
and fell down the well all right dude
you want to come back all right let's
sure
all right did i get i wonder i don't
think i got any boxes did i excited
you're
at that hot eighty percent easier okay
i'm leaving the game
no loop i could just play on your
account i'm too lazy to swap we're just
doing one match uh
well it's not no you're almost you're
almost close right wait what time how
far are we going so
oh until i'm tired okay well then that
changes a lot of things oh my god easy
now
well
you know then i then i might be leveling
my account at that point then all right
tay's back in the hot seat to play some
sick
widowmaker whatever you guys request
that he doesn't feel horrible playing
here i'm going to switch up my account
see the thing is you guys is you might
be like play play this awesome character
but if tay's not good at it you're not
going to see it be awesome anyway the
camera so i can switch characters or it
counts
you're losing your privileges
i'm going to exit this
oh yeah what am i doing wrong
well if i exit this it's going to go to
desktop so i need you to switch a touch
i
see what you mean i got you oh i thought
you were keeping it yeah well i depends
on how long we're playing
how long are we playing for uh as long
as you want you can play another hour if
you want all right then yeah if it's an
hour i'm all sweaty well this room gets
really hot it is it is hot in here um
damn that felt really good
i love
that this game can give you outcomes
like that where you feel so
helpful and so important like a support
for support like lucio or
um
mercy to change the tide of the battle
in such a way that they feel like they
were integral without
dealing very much damage like i didn't
kill that many people but you like
you're constantly moving around you're
harassing the other team you're
bumping health and and movement when you
can and like that changes everything so
it feels really good yeah i mean that's
kind of like one of the things i was
talking about too on the lobby which was
like these those are the type of
memories you know even if it doesn't
last more than a day or two but you'll
remember
pushing that reaper into the well or
like winning that really close match
right what's really awesome
um
see if we can get a
a six stack going mary yeah sorry i do
scream when i get scared so sorry if my
mic peaked i will uh try to do that too
but the truth is
if there is a hanzo
coming at me
my only reaction is to eat
oh the reaper reaper
reaper reaper reaper reaper actually
these are all from the same person nick
jones but that's okay he really wants it
so you want to do a reaper uh sure let
me just see if ed wants to play if he
doesn't then we're just gonna go okay
all right we're just gonna go
we got a four stack what's up guys um
just so you guys know we are in our
seven
uh we've been streaming a lot uh we did
several hours this morning from 10 until
two then we played the uh then we did
the lobby and now we're back at it again
with them vans
i'm mary i'm here with tay what's up we
are so stoked to show you guys this game
and play it with you if you have
questions throw them in the chat i am
listening i'm reading them
um if you guys are watching
on twitch
suck you guys can
definitely make sure to
subscribe to our channel if you guys are
watching on youtube like and subscribe
this video so that we can make more of
these hot things they do check our stats
you know
it's not very cool but they do it so was
reaper the consensus yes i saw a lot i
also saw
i really hope i play good i gotta meet
them
um
toblerone
i'm seeing a few of those as well
i saw a few pharas
sebastian said farah
there's a few and the thing is is
there's so many characters was it 22
there's so many characters
that was close blackjack oh [ __ ] gotcha
turn that beat up baby come on
did you use it gotcha
oh god do we not have a tank any quick
reaper tips somebody asked
like i said i like flanking oh permit
homeboy
wants to know if you got any quick tips
you're a close range yeah you definitely
want to be closed because get up in
their dome
because you like your shotguns don't do
that much damage so far no you're all
about
oh man i want to use wraith for him to
get away and then that wraith form is
basically like your way to survive so
you get right up in people's faces shoot
them in the dome and then use your
wraith to like sneak away
oh
dang good job
yummy coop
it's you and me please i'll try to get
this this hot like 250 health pack
all right that was good that was good
luck and skill
luck lagging [ __ ]
oh sorry lucio i was healers you weren't
fast enough
oh
you're doing work the guy freaking fan
the hammered
no oh
he went through the wall
uh i'm gonna die
maybe
sneak attack sneak attack
and then
just i think you're gonna survive
teleport
it's
away
you need help so bad
i don't know where the rest of them
health packs are on this map they might
have been taken there's one broken down
it's okay it's okay we're gonna
oh reaper first reaper that was my
health pack thrill also i had armor
which helped
oh you had multiple
oh give me the triple dang
damn it i know that could have been play
the game play trip oh no he's low though
oh
who is in front of me kenti why
all you had to do was hit him one time
ah that was a good that was a good play
by mr road
that's fine we did some work there uh
quick tips yeah you want to use your
teleport to get into sneaky spots get
behind them
if things are [ __ ] hits the fan you know
shift away use your wraith form totally
and just be yeah close oh they just
broke it down
that was good move by tracer
oh that was equally a good move
oh get out played
yeah someone asked if this game is out
it's out it's no longer in beta you can
buy it it's forty dollars on pc sixty
dollars with the uh first set of skins
and it's like a nice pack that gives you
a bunch of extra bonus stuff
uh and then it's 60 on console xbox one
and ps4 and i think it just comes with
the pack you don't get the 40 option
nice
he might die die actually
oh he's i how did you know you just
thought because he was going through
this like when he's going to through
everyone it's pretty uh it's like a
pretty obvious tell he got a triple
though on that he might get played the
game because of that noise
i'm annoyed that he might get play the
game by that but whatever is what it is
you didn't get made of the game yet i
know don't remind me
i will play a zenyatta game after this
though there's no way i'm not going to
toblerone 15 eliminations when you like
you're darn right tay's not bad
tay's pretty good i'm all right we're
playing some i feel like we're playing
some you know
like you know average players not crazy
we got some really good people on
gamespot actually they haven't put a lot
of work into it chris waters and danny
o'dwyer been doing these um
hot hero guide hero guides and they've
been putting in so many hours to get the
proper hero guides
that are done correctly and i you gotta
give them a lot of credit they've been
doing great work um
as well as reviewer mike mccarty whose
review is going live tomorrow morning
it's already done it's already set in
stone they're just making a video to go
along with it it's going to be awesome
so
if you guys are interested in gamespot's
review you can check it out tomorrow
morning it goes live
man if only you had your alt they're
like all stuck in there like a bunch of
dumb dumbs
you guys don't have a healer
we're not lucio
yeah yeah no
actually that was a bad idea what i just
did which was back myself in the corner
all right
i wish i'd alt
you're gonna annoy them
oh
i love reverse reaper
i freaking
she's gonna
kill you dead if you're not careful
oh i just got all damn it
oh it's trying to stall for my team
did you think you got yeah brought back
for a second i thought i got brought
back but uh that was not the case
see like look how long it takes for you
to like
nah never mind i guess it's not that bad
walk
that's why i gotta do the hot teleport
the hot teleport oh we gotta go and play
the game yeah this is it
oh man
now i'm gonna die duh that was
heartbreaking yeah i knew it was a
really bad idea at half-life
i think he caught the bullets too which
is like really smart on his part
where the heck is the rest of the team
oh we're gonna find out if we're going
to a third map because it kind of feels
that way we're getting dominated on this
map
sometimes that happens
high noon
nice
this is it this is your final stand
oh you guys are in trouble
no
oh you were in there
that's my fault
if i had went in instead of chasing the
reaper we would have won
went for kills instead of objectives
exactly
that was my fault i appreciate your
ability to take the heat though although
like
what the hell was the rest
where were they
smooth voltage double tracer thank you
if you melee with reaper just after
reloading you get your guns back about a
second faster i don't know that was true
we'll try it
put it together
instead of reloading
um melee with reaper just after
reloading oh
okay
all right try it give it a whirl
oh he was on the other side
maybe i didn't see any uh
say goodbye to your men i like it all
right pro tip i like it
they're coming in with a vengeance
you do not have full health i know
nice doing work that's fine i'll take
the trade it was not a good position
that mercy's healing too which is super
annoying
she just revived him which is equally
annoying you should take out the mercy
yeah i was trying
but the reaper was next to her and i
didn't have full life too mercy's really
bad oh no they're about to take the
point
uh i think
i think they're contesting us off of it
nice
oh i forgot to do the melee thing
you forgot to do the melee thing
there's more important things than melee
things it's winning this is a really
good trick
because it works
look at that yeah you don't even need
that it's like canceling an animation
that's awesome
damn
good call oh my god
does that help okay
it might not have been reloaded until
just now
dang
let's not do that no
let's uh get this help instead so
remember the job is to contest the point
so as long as you're safe in the point
he gives a [ __ ]
oh oh he pulled him into the hole that
was actually really cool
you might want to do your alt pretty
soon
you need help though
oh
she went after you
i could have did it but i don't know if
i would have lived so then i didn't do
it and i was trying to run for help and
now we're not on the point and mike is
clearly
doing something
talking he typed out alt ready don't you
know the
the emote wheel
chris he likes a personal
preference yeah you think so
oh she's coming after you
too bad she's
slow she might still kill me here maybe
oh my god you're so [ __ ] at range like
you're a guns not you as a human
oh
yes
nice
you do so you do so little damage at
range
did you spray
that little i forgot about that man you
got a bm like in old school cs
oh no
he's behind you it's a tracer
oh group just punched her off
oh that's so rewarding
mercy what happened
man you get that guy in the back
nice
could be play the game i don't know it's
only a two but you had two before it was
it
all natural
hey where you running
i'll keep you guys over here if you want
to be entertained
that's fine that's fine i mean if they
don't get to the oh there's someone at
the point there was someone at the i
just wanted to stall for the team to you
know
i should have just
walked away that was really cool you
guys are at 99 yeah but remember you
came back from 99. i sure did tay you
don't you never take anything for
granted here
oh [ __ ] they're pushing hard
you just tack fizer too
ah that doesn't count as contesting the
point
well
what
it's still going on
you guys are in trouble oh
i know
i told you it wasn't guaranteed oh no
it's a cinderella story no no no no
please don't say that
this would devastate me your alt is up
and like
really quickly
basically you get one kill you can all
this would break my heart if we lost
don't
think like that tay
oh you almost got hooked yeah i did but
i didn't but then i didn't
nice
get work here i'll contest the point
i'll capture it oh you're crazy matt why
would you do that
oh no
can tracer
you guys are capturing almost
yes yes this is it
keep them at bay
alt it
yes
yes
yes if oh my god yeah that's right i'll
stall them out i'll stall them out i'll
do a stupid one kill alt
one good
why not
actual ginger you don't see a lot of i
like seeing tracers
yep so you can just warp back
not there
oh come on
there's four of you
okay he's stuck
oh he got two off of that sticky
nice
all right gotta give the healer i go to
the healer
oh should we get chris i feel like chris
wants it
oh yeah loot box
let's go
all right let me try to get chris
i'm assuming he wants in he was
spectating victory
and we'll open the box come on
legendary skin one time
i hope you get a yeah you got the same
box i did it pharma for me it sure is
you got a bunch of sprays hey
monk beard from diablo you gonna rock it
who cares wow
wow it's about the little things mary uh
skins are all i care about yeah i do too
let's see that skin
show me the skin you're looking at my
arm which is my skin
no it's not gonna
all right who are you gonna play i don't
know
um maybe a zenyatta or we can try
widowmaker because everyone was asking
but i'm i'm a
subpar
super widowmaker what do you guys think
about zenyatta zenyatta is really rad to
see especially done well
lee jiang is a tough one
all right what did they say
they said good stall tay because it was
a good stall i wouldn't tracer might be
okay here i don't know oh i'll be
playing tracer that's fine play tracer
toblerone
toblerone zarya
i'm someone's already zarya it's a big
all right well then that person at least
gets some genji
and we did a genji it didn't go so hot
you don't want to watch that you don't
want to see that
player's choice
all right
let's try it out we'll see if we can do
this
what's your favorite pokemon character
mine
yeah it's random that was the question
vanille
character or pokemon
yeah you said pokemon pokemon character
was the question so like what's a
character oh brock
brock samson
is that his last name
i'm so slow
i don't know okay i was like what is up
with your body
you know i said indian are they like an
all pharah team
god i could really use some healing
discord
throw it at some people
man you guys need some heels
this is true
i don't do enough damage to kill him
oh i should be discord orbiting him
this game is good on the ps4 i also need
to heal my teammates i don't know i
guess it depends on if you like playing
with the controller
i don't not this kind of game
here's the thing too
oh
you got through
correct
mike where's the bubble now you got to
watch it again now you get to watch that
wasn't yeah now i got wrecked
i should never be that close um if there
is a game that i could play on the couch
instead of at a computer desk i will do
it because i love sitting on my couch
and playing a good game but you can't
play this on a couch i don't think can
you not i mean you can i just don't want
to yo
i feel like it wouldn't be comfortable
seems like wow get two shotted you sure
did
need to get in there maybe you should
change up
see the beauty about this game is you
can change your character
you definitely don't want to waste it so
i should alt first and then swap that's
the one caveat if anything
caveat caviar
it's pronounced caveat
let's go let's go let's go let's go
what's in there
oh the pharah
nice all
good job
that was a good no no pharaoh
that was a good alt
i can't believe i didn't die there
you need to heal
your buns there should be a heal outside
i only have
150 so there's not much to heal
oh wait you are healed
and contested
they're contesting
i can't believe they're not walking
around and trying to attack it from
other areas they're like all going in
the front it seems like a mistake not
doing any damage to them
i think it's because they have like
double heal
this is kind of a waste of an old maybe
yep and i have no way out okay rip
rip
all right
well that was fun
don't worry guys i'll i'll stop for ot
in this corner
i think we lost oh not yet
there's nothing wrong with playing with
a controller
i just don't want to play this game with
the controller i want the control
of a keyboard and mouse with this game
um but a lot of people like to play um
rocket league with a
keyboard
mouse um
and i really like rocket league with the
controller
um a lot of like campaign games if i can
play them with the controller i'd prefer
to do that
dude we have three tanks
nice no it's not that's why none of the
pharah's or anything we're dying
going with old lucio em yeah this is
that
dude all right
we gotta go the long way
to chris
no
chris
is so fast
oh man iced i'll heal you from this side
of the wall nice good job
great you're doing work
oh you got another lucio uh
i don't think he was aiming
for he was
alive teammates good job
good gerber
you got the point great
now keep it
maybe behind me behind
man mae's probably really good in this
level she can ice people out
oh okay
how come i didn't hear oh
i think i turned it off
i was like how come i didn't hear the
audio cue that she was doing that and i
think i turned off the uh alt audio cue
really yeah
nice
shields for everyone
yeah get her down on the ground and then
kill her don't forget to right click to
boost them out of the way it's a really
nice way to knock them off there
oh they see they got a healer they got a
mercy
see that mercy
taking out all the work you're
in doing yeah
run
nice
scream eh
oh my god i didn't hear it again
that's a
shame supposed to hear justice reigns
from above damn it
there's this
exactly now i'll never know
no goo
you can't be in there alone
i'm not alone
are you here
who's with you this isn't here somewhere
it was
oh i can do it
did it
i don't know who it hit i got three got
mike and chris
oh male 1 heel heel oh you're dead
i got melted or frozen
well we're contesting and they're not
like taking it from us so that's good
get their back
i'm not even saying sentences anymore
don't get their back get their back
oh okay we're at 99 we just gotta hold
hold the line
stay with me
last stand
see ya
nice alt by mike to keep him away noise
he sucked him out of the area
yes
maybe you should get your battle cries
back
sounds like those are important to you
i don't know what it is though
the in-game voice
yeah i think it is
yeah there you go
classic
this map is so interesting
it's good
it's got a really nice high ceilings
uh-oh
nice
way to get them off here
heels up yeah
oh he just dropped the b2 what a dirt
oh
you know you can't hit him
raising the void
all right and you're also already back
up
oh there's a
look up
yeah there's a lot of [ __ ]
yep easy peasy noise lemon squeezy
gg
play the game no i doubt it
definitely not
did he stick someone
oh yeah
oh the hot dublay maybe a triple
maybe yeah sort of a pseudo careful
assist trip
oh we'll give mma hearty uh oh wow he
had 29 limbs that's pretty good
epic i should have voted for you so i'll
be my bed
career best in healing
i'll take it
great
great job exactly
all right what are you motivated to do
now i don't know
what does that mean like who am i
motivated to play yep
ah
i don't know we'll play
yep yep
i can try to play
widowmaker all right
all right we'll try
you can do it
i don't know it's not it's it's not
supposed to be that hard but i i
don't have the patience sometimes so i
kind of just
panic a little bit
i need that awp so my problem is is uh
with widowmaker you have to be
constantly moving like shifting left and
right so that you don't get sniped and i
can't snipe moving left and right like
that so i always end up
kind of getting sniped myself it happens
it becomes like a headshot war kind of
thing i fighting another one i hate the
headshot war widowmaker
one shot i thought ed was serious when
he said all dashing luckily it wasn't a
true story
all bastion
an all-bastion team would be so silly
looking
i've done that for defense six genjis
we've done it for defense
did it work uh yeah we won but i think
that was like in the alpha when people
weren't really knowledgeable of how to
properly take care of that kind of stuff
attackers incoming in 30 seconds i don't
like this
oh it's got a yellow tear blind skin
let's see how i do with danny's mouse
all right you got a winston
nice ah
the headshot war has begun damn it
i kind of thought it was a widow were
you moving around no i was shooting the
pharaoh
oh she got you real quick too
so like a good sniper will make you feel
like crap about yourself that's all
right which is why i typically avoid
depends on how many of those happen
one's okay you know one or two is okay
if that keeps happening then we can't if
i won't
stay on that character this character
for too long but we'll see
nice third time's a charm one out of
three ain't bad
she's looking for you
the headshot war continues
she's supposed to kill us
that's a shame that's very situated i
don't know how this zenyatta lived he
had like one pixel i should have just
stayed there
i should have spot oh chris i like it oh
that maybe not so much
it worked out
oh
what the headshot war continued
oh my god she headshotted you with a
grenade
it's a rocket to the face that's so much
easier then knocked sniping loaded let's
be real here oh yeah
oh they're not even here
oh god
oh
oh you're waiting eh
here it comes
[ __ ] your bubble
genji's looking for you
nice
he's upset
you guys can't see him but he's obsessed
i just hooked myself towards the bomb
i've done that before oh my god i've
also killed me so you know where that
happens to me a lot
thank you it's
like playing healers and stuff and you
like
that you go towards the battle that's
killing you
mercy
nice
oh come back
finish
oh no
dead shot
oh come on give me a break diva i just
got away from everyone else
they have good teamwork so far
i don't know what's worse this or genji
but i have them i had the most kills on
the team which is not a good not a good
sign
i expect chris waters to do work
i don't know who he's playing right now
okay
how did that happen
i know i'm gonna try to snipe while on a
platform that's really tough to do
nice
or is it is i guess this is your this is
where you shine
oh my god
don't worry guys we're coming back we're
gonna we're gonna go back the other way
yeah just keep going
hey hey we're having a duel
me and that other widowmaker that is
rude
do you not oh what
on the floor with you
watch out
oh my god both tanks are here
they both altered though
did they know that
have you used your
little smoke at all yet i barely i think
you're two
idiot
that's your butt
oh did he get him
it's either diva or widowmaker it was a
skinny lady who's a skinny lady a skinny
minnie
oh
that is like a straight up snipe off you
guys have wait watch out
got her
i don't care i won the war
i won it doesn't matter i don't care
what that winston did
[ __ ]
i mean
to be fair oh man this sucks like
snipers win games easily if you're
taking out her sniper from being able to
snipe then you're doing a really good
job through the iris
but
this doesn't look good for you guys
i don't charge it long enough
you're impatient
nice job there's a widowmaker on the
other side of this
come on keep your head up kick your head
out
pretty little head out careful
oh
nice job great work
you're pissing her off i'll tell you
that right now
we need to start the payload
stop
payload where's my bros
you have no bros
you're brawless
clearly
like please please don't please just oh
chris was there
it's not dude we're gonna hold the line
we're gonna hold the line oh oh my god
we're gonna
push them back
what is that
[ __ ]
indeed
indeed
no no no no no no no no no no no get on
the point no no get on the board
oh my god hold the line
stay
use your little smoky thing too
oh my god snipe off
jesus i'm the worst sniper in the world
oh tay
you're so damn fast
stupid
she kills you
this is a
snipe off
i can't believe you guys held the line
so far
oh god
get out of there
good job that's great
oh no she's trying to hold the line
she's she's contesting
with their stupid mech face
ah
someone no you guys can't all beat back
there you've got to be on the point
it's heartbreaking
well
i want to say we went
ooh that was cool
oh damn
oh i die here nobody watch
i die here it's like a tunnel of death
for her like wow
have some free kills
okay we'll get the salty attack run back
goob
goob's the only one
you gotta show your teammates man
trapped is what got us a card
ugh
no no
no no
salty tay dude man salts
salts
do you can't even run it back give us
the run back
did we not get the run back
all right so you're gonna play
streamer's choice what is the what is oh
it's my choice
um i'll read you what other people say
people are saying you're salty which is
true always salty
oh they all left and i've been playing
the same team
i wanted re-vengeance oh
come on
it's like they knew i wanted vengeance
they knew
it's your favorite movie
clearly gladiator gladiator
uh what about you oh my god i don't know
that's such a
wide question as soon as i answer it i'd
be like no wait
it's not
just kidding
right now
mad max i'd watch that [ __ ] every day
yeah it's a pretty good one it's so good
we are attacking
roadhog
is that what we're doing
sure
what's your favorite movie
i'm hearing oh now people are coming in
tow bastian zarya farah diva genji
the whole roster reaper i'm still there
so that's the thing is like when
everybody's everyone
uh we just did reaper so
oh mercy team yeah right i actually
tried that one time
we got wrecked
how are you with zarya
i'm okay she's a little bit more
complicated because you want to get the
shield
it's out and you want the shields to
take damage because that'll lead to your
cannon doing more damage
um and she's also good for when you have
a character like a reaper or someone
like a winston that wants to be in the
fray
because then you want to be bubbling
them constantly but if there's not
someone that wants to get in people's
faces you probably don't want to
use that
they got a pretty good spot up there
this is not gonna go well
i'm gonna go around because
that looks really bad
that's dead already to a
thing
it's already dead
let's see some good hooking
oh
that is smart
i just wanted to kill the there you go
look i am like phasing through the wall
what
it's good though she got she trapped you
yeah she did i can't argue with that you
cannot argue with good may play
your only weakness when you get really
salty is good may play
damn that's a good may play gotta give
props
should be healing chris
hey someone needs to kill that back
real talk
like one of the freakin
oh man he like followed you
wow that blocked the freaking
all right
all right
either i was too far or the turret
blocked i'm guessing too
far back for more
sorry this is going you're back for more
yes maybe i can hook him he's gonna
come from behind us
enemy turrets
oh where is my okay
you are getting made all day
no okay nice
hook
oh eat it may
dang you know i really thought your gun
would do more damage than that
i'm amazed she got away i'm amazed
listen to me
yep
okay
i am
he used his alt though all right guys
this is not going so hard
you're gonna make it to the first place
for sure
i'm gonna make it to the first place
yeah like you have
the first
checkpoint
oh yeah you guys are pretty close
oh are you
you over it is that what just happened
me yeah yeah
i said i was switching
he's like i want to win oh my god he's
hiding in winston's dead body
well he's doing work
i'm doing no work no i meant that guy
yes
i didn't mean you
that's a bastion i would assume he's
going to do some type of work
okay at
least okay oh my god
you're so floaty
i'm so good
it's all right you're gonna get it
are we though yeah
back online uh
well we don't have a tank
that doesn't seem right
no it doesn't
i'll switch after i use assault
i'm getting shot from behind oh you were
that's a shame
that's like me right like i never know
that i'm being killed until i'm dead and
then i look at the replay i'm like wow
that person shot me five times and i
didn't notice
oh so you got it
you got the first
checkpoint uh did we yeah it's red
isn't it
you guys only have like a minute left
nice
don't forget you have your oh god
no don't pick me off bastion you son of
a [ __ ]
the bastion reinhardt combo is so
frustrating i need like a genji right
now
well you gotta use your alt gotta hurry
up
music it's kind of tough in that small
area with the bash and just like maybe
if i go around
up on the payload
all right may just use her old
screw it
what is that guy doing oh yeah they're
in that little pocket
oh bastion [ __ ]
just hurt his ass
there he goes
you got one minute you guys got some
so like don't forget to escort the
payload what's the payload oh god you
just got a triple
yikes oh
yolo
oh i feel like a reinhardt's hitting me
i'm gonna die
i'm on the edge
he's still chasing me i know but
she's him
she doesn't see me idiot okay
you have to escort the payload
no you're too busy cheesing people my
espionage
we just got work that's all it is
if you can contest it you guys have a
whole group maybe you guys can do one
last push
great work that's how you get worked
damn
are you crying
like a bastion
oh see
that's just disheartening
forte it's okay we're not playing those
guys again
see folks when things get bad and you
get rolled like that you just don't play
them again
all right so you're gonna play
you're gonna play may
yeah probably
let's go back let's end on a high this
is probably it for us
this is true
so we'll finish her off with a good may
play
hopefully
you can do it tay can we though i
believe in you thank you
that's all i need
um
you also need to win
probably that's true
your defenses
i really need a may skin
how much you play area it seems like it
would be valuable to you but
unfortunately you can't just buy one can
you tay you have to buy
loot boxes and then you have to open
them and hope
for a skin or hope
for
coins
so that you can
spend it
and for a legendary skin it's a thousand
a colorway
colorway
yeah how much money do you have 200 i
think
some paltry amount oh peasant money
i would not think
a warrior's greatest weapon
destination
yeah because you're not really i mean i
guess you're a little bit of a distance
but they're all on the right side
they're all on the right oh they're all
genji's
they went five genji
they're going around i think
they look like they're trying to like
get around the map
that is so funny that you saw that
they're coming
fine
so many games
damn nice
heel
that was
close
you know your ice is really good against
genji yep i agree
i wonder if they're gonna rethink their
plan no they're gonna go around again
that that's pretty good
i didn't even know you could do that
oh i heard them
it's raining
ninja stars ninja stars
oh nice try
cube
oh
you got the kill
at some point they'll give up the strat
i'm pretty sure
that's what
that's what they want you to think oh
yeah
the strat is for you to think that
they've given up on the strap the meta
and then morgange
definitely don't fire back then when
they're deflecting
that'll be good um your alts will be
good if they try to contest and they're
like winning
oh he's so close
yeah you're dead
maybe they're just a bunch of
youngins youtubers
oh dang there was six
i should just have our team like group
up on me so that when they come after us
i'll just alt and then they'll just all
get frozen yeah you just gotta make sure
you don't die that's all
this is true that is sound advice
and like chris's weapons are good for
countering the genji too i think
out of here oh my god they're not even
uh i hear k.o ken
yeah get frozen dang
these butt heads
look at you following
some type of acrobat
try squirreling
swirling yeah that's where you jump left
and right really sporadically because
you don't know what you're doing let me
shoot at people
that's a good squirrel
what about six mays
that'd be fun
maybe i'll pick another character you
jerk
60 seconds
but this is not i feel like you don't
admire it i think you're
telling them they
are being silly
all right this is a poor
decision on their part
damn it
did he just back off
much better
oh he's deflected
30
well this was a fun game guys
are they even trying
i don't know
i would assume we're gonna see some
genji alts here
they just all alt at the same time
you're almost you're also almost up too
if you just do a little bit more you can
put a nice thing down and basically
secure your victory i mean a play of the
game is what you're talking about
oh tranquility
did i get it
got him
how do you even get to play the game for
this oh of course
come on the old toblerone
you should be ashamed of yourself
mahardi
he didn't even do anything
he gets
he gets no accolades
why does he get epic because the whole
other team did it
yeah they're all sad because they're all
genji
six kenji
at least we didn't go six bastion they
would have hard countered us so hard
yeah
tell your team six may
the genji tactic failed all right maybe
the whole
tactic will work
all may
all right we're doing it stream they all
may
oh my god this is gonna be so silly
yeah all right
tell him shoot icicles he'll be fine
oh what if you like
too many defense heroes too many of one
hero
i don't think they're working together
no okay okay where's
jake
now someone else do it oh can you not
can we not build a
huge ice ball
that would be sick
but why [ __ ]
i don't know so you know how vertically
high we could get it would be like
the ice wall beanstalk oh great all
right let's just all troll each other
let's just never get out oh
oh that is smart but then if there's a
pharaoh or screw right anyone who can
basically jump over it also it would
only box people out for like four
seconds oh they're all hanzos
hanzo versus mae hanzo versus may
it's a massacre
damn it it's a massacre who would have
knew theirs would do more damage
we just gotta get to the thing
just
hurl more maze at them
let's go let's dance you wanna
curl as many mays as you can dude i
wanted to dance with that guy you guys
are getting slaughtered no we're not
we're we're slowly pushing the
oh crap
i don't know who you're messing with i'm
a
cold sniper
maybe not
dude we're both missing each other like
crazy well
oh yeah
all right
okay
look at all the ice walls
oh why
why did you ice wall he was a free
target
slow wall progress
inch board with our ice cocoons
oh what a shot
oh dude could you imagine
seeing six hanzo alts oh but we could
just ice block it that's fine
that could have gone better that could
have gone better i agree i agree with
you may
all may all day
if we get the capture point that's
considered oh we're on the point
oh get on the point get there get there
get there
just ice block on the point
more ice blocks
you need more ice bucks
oh yeah
yeah what about it what about your old
it's stupid
you're stupid all right
more ice walls oh how did he get me
they're just kidding
you guys
all right
let's go i'm ready to start a blizzard
all right
oh no did we just team wipe no where's
the where's the team at
oh contested come on come on come on no
did we all die there's our two may
deaths right there yeah
watch out it's not gonna hit me
that's that much though
oh come on
why wouldn't whoever was next why
wouldn't whoever was next to me blocked
them instead of trapped them
clearly we're not thinking this through
guys it could have been
could have been a new may player all
right it's all right it's all right
come on oh
we're on the objective you can do it all
right we're gonna do it we're doing it
this is going okay
this is the best
oh
nice icicle
it doesn't matter
everyone to death
yes yes
yes yeah that's right capture point
number one now for capture point b
that's correct
oh where you going
nice try that's why you don't run away
wiener
punch in the old buttocks the old
bootaroo can we climb this
you can
on me all day
oh what a shot crimson
jackass
it's a good feather dude
this is a good map we might do it
the kids are doing pretty good
we're definitely getting in there
like this is a good map for you guys i'm
not doing so hot this is also a really
good lesson in the lines of
may versus
visit yeah
this is great really contesting right
now
you're just seeing different characters
battle it out
oh
i'm on the objective come join me i'll
come join you okay
sucks because that guy's up high
i would have got him
oh yeah we're getting the objective go
go go go come on
gourmet
throw your rolls
i wish i was there to see it
oh it stopped
my ultimate is charging like imagine if
you kept throwing alt at their uh spawn
point they would never get out they
would never get out
oh there you go
nice
more eyes oh we need we need shield
walls bros
use one
where is it
there was no escape there was nowhere
for you to go
damn you guys are so close go we got
four minutes got plenty of time i want
to see it
oh it's going all the way back down i
love this may attack
come on
my ultimate is ready
my ultimate is ready we need to just
layer our shields
oh that someone just died
oh we're going in twos oh no we're just
getting snipped
get him hardy
oh i'm so sorry ed
nice
all right this could be it
this could be good this looks really
good
save your ice wall oh i just got pushed
out by my own teammate it's okay love
you through
what's up
stay on it stay on it
ice wall it's coming
they're gonna do it you're gonna do it
we're doing it you're doing it peter i
got uh-oh
no
don't ruin the moment you ruined the
moment you stupid ass
yeah
that's playing the game may
we did it
hey we got one non-match in may
get out of here goobs
that's how we do all your animation
isn't that rad yep right here look at
that hot triple
we get that other guy too that jerk that
comes later
but we'll take it
so good yeah
what a game what a way to end it
dude that was rad that was good hanzo vs
may if you guys ever wanted to know what
the result would be oh i got loot crate
too what you want to open it real fast
and then one all right let's do it
all right we deserve a legendary right
may all day
dang it three blues though a little gold
we'll take a
little bit of gold is good
a little like 50 50. peasant peasant
gold you'll take it though you'll pick
those pennies up right out of the gutter
damn it you're so right put them in your
pocket
that's a good way to end it uh yeah
you guys
may all day
may all day
that was rad uh thank you guys for
joining us on our awesome overwatch
stream that lasted all day oh i am
beat that was fun yeah uh you guys i
hope you guys got to enjoy it we did two
streams one from 10 until two then the
lobby two to three and then we just
played overwatch some more from three
until oh my god was it 6 30. so this has
been a really good all-day stream you
guys uh our review of overwatch
is out tomorrow morning 6 00 am i think
gamespot.com
we will have our review of overwatch
reviewer mike mccarty is
uh he already has decided he has written
it it is being
made right now you guys will see it 6
a.m tomorrow don't forget to check back
also if you guys are watching this on
youtube don't forget to like and
subscribe this video it helps us out uh
they do check that stuff uh twitch
subscribe to us for more streams
and gamespot
you guys are doing a great job just keep
up keep doing what she did do it that's
all good stuff uh thank you guys so much
uh today you did some serious may work
we did it congrats uh
you know i'm happy that we got over that
real terrible salty loss before that but
all may all day all may all day
thank you guys so much for joining us i
hope you guys had a rad time we will be
streaming much more in the next few days
so
keep a looking out for that oh also we
have a bunch of overwatch character
guides uh on gamespot and on youtube so
check those out you guys can see uh from
people who've been playing it since the
very beginning all the hot tips that you
guys need to be
overwatch pros and go may all day
see ya
you